I love the show I think that there are
just so many interesting layers of the
story to dig into and explore and I'm
completely hooked what was it like for
you guys reading this was it the same
way I mean did you get hooked on the
story when you were reading the script
what made you want to be a part of
telling the story for me you know the
thing that I thought stood out the most
was that the show is tackling these
these very grand philosophical questions
that are obviously put forth in the
novel and talking about society and
talking about class and talking about
sexuality and but your guide through all
of it is that you're living through the
way that those things manifest
themselves in the day to day moments of
moment emotional experience the people
in these worlds and I thought the way in
which each scene was the most emotional
messy version of what these people's
lives and intimate lives are like was
the most was was such a more compelling
way to get at that and felt much more
human and much more real than something
that might be you know more prescriptive
or something the look of these lands is
very important and if those visuals
aren't there II could feel very cheaper
like a set as opposed to a real place so
what was it to in conversations with the
creative team that really sort of
reassured you and really sold you on the
vision that they had for this and how
they would bring it to life I think
going in the scope of what was going to
be needed to make this as grand as it
needed to be was something that they
were clearly committed to and you could
see that in what was being built and for
me I you know was really existing only
in the savage lands and surprisingly
that took a lot to create to create that
epochal own kind of world of the future
I just think it was clear from the
get-go if you're gonna do this you have
to do it
I was it the same for you Alden
especially because I mean you get to be
in both of these places yeah I thought
that the just the aesthetic choices they
made and one thing they didn't do is you
think they put the look of the show is
believable in both the savage lands and
in New London as worlds that people
would have created they do know so sort
of sci-fi with it or or apocalyptic with
it that it's then it feels like comic
book II or like a genre Newell's like in
some sense these worlds are justified by
what humans might create for themselves
as a utopia I mean a lot of New London
looks like renderings of kind of
forward-thinking you go shopping malls
or whatever that exists now so that I
felt again couched it in the humanity of
it and kept it in a get like eight it is
sci-fi but it's using sci-fi to talk
about the world were in now and reflect
that back to us as opposed to create an
escape from it so really is
so cinematic and it's so impressive to
see what has been accomplished with it
how did this shoot feel during the
production did it feel like it was on
the level of anything you've done in
film in many respects yes the thing
that's different to me is that in a film
project it's more director driven so I
is the first series I've really done
getting wrapping my head around the
staggered version of the power hierarchy
or playing you know who the boss is
who's you know who's setting that tone
that's a lot clearer when it's you know
a director or you know on a film
especially a writer director and film so
yeah yeah that was the only aspect it
felt kind of different but that said
like the directors we had were really
strong and kind of be there was a real
intention to make this feel like a film
and I think the cinematography also
really speaks to that I too haven't
really I've never done a series but
keeping the look of it you know like
there were
moments that we had in some of those
scenes that felt like a Swedish film the
lighting was so rich and and was telling
so much of the story along you know with
with everything else
Alton does this compare in any way to a
soup or something like soullow does the
Star Wars universe still feel bigger
than anything else you've done or is the
scope of this pretty on that level the
scope of this is pretty big it's not
quite Star Wars you know Star Wars
really lives in the spectacle of these
things whereas this really lives in the
moment a moment kind of person a person
up at all and yeah you know it's it
feels so different you know it feels it
felt really different because this
really felt essentially like a drama and
a love story and you know there's
there's a great sense of humor to it and
a sense of satire but it's really
grounded whereas the fun of Star Wars
and the enjoyment of it is that it's a
completely different world that people a
little bit like you know in this fun way
that's somewhat camp and somewhat
stylized so you know yeah this felt this
didn't feel maybe having come off Star
Wars it didn't feel like a sci-fi thing
at all what I really loved Solo and the
Kaster that I thought that was such a
fun movie and it's it's cool to see this
as a follow-up to that and and are you
still hoping that you might get to
reprise Solo at some point we'll see I
don't know you know they're they're
figuring out what Star Wars looks like
in our world today and you know in all
ways with the media landscape
everything's so different with the
streaming surfaces and everything so
we'll see what comes of it I think
what's exciting is that we're living in
a time where there's a lot of
out-of-the-box thinking around what this
one the mother-son relationship between
your characters really is crucial to
this story and getting the audience to
want to follow their journey when did
you guys first meet and what helped you
and establishing that relationship
well we've met in Wales I think was it
Wales are in London maybe but anyway it
was it was over on the other side of the
world at the root of it it's it's a you
know it's a mother that wants the best
for her son what she believes is the
best but you know there's an interesting
immediate difference between their two
worlds which is Linda's understanding of
sexuality comes from New London and
which is obviously it's more free there
is no monogamy it's a social body and I
think that spills over into her behavior
towards her son that would be in some
ways a bit unnatural for what we
consider to be a mother-son relationship
your character also has a very distinct
look it's different from how we're used
to seeing you so when it came to
exploring the character how did that
help you in finding her and what is what
is the real fun and getting lost in the
character in that way well you know that
someone who's never went from never
experiencing pain to being abandoned and
left to have a child and I think the
look was you know also remembering that
people in New London don't age they
don't fall apart and everything about
what her life had has become his
survival and the look was something
actually that you know the creative team
really wanted to you know to try and to
really take it away and it be somewhat
unexpected but it's really yeah I really
you know she's really broken this you
know woman but yet still trying to keep
some semblance of
activeness it's a interesting concept
and the themes of this world because it
seems that forcing people to participate
in pleasure seems to somewhat take the
pleasure away from it all do you guys
both personally feel like happiness
comes more from a balance of things
rather than over indulging in any one
thing like these characters seem to kind
of try to do I mean I I think that those
well happiness can only come from within
you number one you know and and I think
that in this you know dystopian world
where you know I think you're a hundred
percent right that any like to be to be
it's like almost like I wrote that the
social body Zak actions are you know no
different than I'm getting up and having
breakfast and I can't I think that it it
takes away in a sense or I could see
that it could take away the magic um but
like anything if it's the only thing you
know then it's the only thing you know
yeah I mean only through Aldens
character do we get to really live what
it might be for our experience to be
stepping into it and and learning a new
way of of existing yeah yeah I'd also
say that like the the pressure for
happiness or for that there's certain
feelings that are okay and there's
certain feelings that aren't or they're
certain feelings are good and certain
feelings that aren't and again this is
like this is using side by to talk about
our worry so a massive ignorance around
fulfillment our happiness needing to
look a certain way or have a certain
quality to it and and that bad feelings
are bad to have
yeah I think there's a lot of wisdom in
oxley about that and about the trap of
that when you're disowning feelings that
come up in you things you might have
fear anxiety pain grief anger if those
things are being buried the the
happiness you're running through isn't
quite on a real foundation what do you
think would most surprised people about
what it takes to pull off a show like
this I think the orgy scenes know these
people who were doing those scenes for
such enormous troopers and you know we
were shooting it's 3:00 in the morning
in the middle of a Welsh forest and
there's a mud in the middle of that
forest waiting for hours and be given
lunches in little boxes and whatever and
they just had a great great attitude
about it and had a great sense of humor
about it and that was very surreal to
get used to it's a whole new suffering
for your art more on their part I mean I
was I didn't get to seen it that but I
was in watching it to like you see I
like I just even the choreography of
them of the movements of it yeah like
even all of that I can't imagine what
what happens have taken yeah incredibly
like the orchestration of all that was
really was really phenomenal and to make
sure everyone's comfortable and all of
that it actually again it actually looks
really beautiful were there aspects of
these characters for you that you
particularly enjoyed getting to explore
because they were things that you had
never had the chance to play before yeah
there's something in mean there was
definitely things like stepping into
Linda you know there when someone is as
she is in the beginning which is
early unconscious it's very interesting
kind of the level of freedom and one
hand that exists in their
irresponsibility in there I don't know
that [ __ ] and just going to the you know
how out of control she actually really
was was really an I don't know if I've
never done that but it was certainly an
interesting part of the arc of somebody
who wakes up to seizing what she sees is
the moment she's that she's been waiting
for there's a kind of bomb jaded it's
jiff then there's a kind of hostility
and fun there's a term from this book
that's I'm gonna [ __ ] it out but it was
a dark pleasure of soured romanticism
and there was an element of that whereas
in a lot of other roles that I've played
I was playing you know how I felt for a
long time deeply idealistic and romantic
and there's there's still that in here
but it has some other edges to it that
were really fun well thank you both for
talking to me I'm very impressive this
so I can't wait to see how it all plays
out